- Today's going to be a bit special
because today's video is a reaction video.
We will together look at a video
from one of the very
large content creator's
in the sphere of consulting out there.
Her name is Kchoi.
I trust that many of you
have already come across
of some of her videos.
I believe she does great content
on the topic of consulting.
I inserted a link to the channel below
in the video description so check it out
if you want to see more.
In the video we're going
to talk about today,
she is talking about the pros
and cons of consulting
from her perspective.
And I believe that consulting
is a very heterogeneous field with lots
of different types of firms present.
So while now I watching the video,
I will frequently stop
and share my experiences
as a former McKinsey consultant.
I will reflect on what she is saying,
and then give you my perspective
on whether I believe
that this is also true
for an MBB context or where
there might be some differences.
So trust, this is really
going to be valuable
for you if you are asking
yourself whether consulting
is the right career
choice for you to pursue.
So welcome on my channel Firm Learning,
but now without further
ado, let's jump into it.
- The first pro is that
when you're a consultant,
you usually get to work in a
lot of different industries.
This is great if you don't
have a particular interest
or passion in one industry,
whether that's healthcare
or consumer goods
or anything like that
because in consulting,
you usually get access and opportunities
in all different kinds of industries.
- So let me start here.
What she says is that
usually as a consultant
you get access to lots of industries,
and of course, this is true,
and this is correct in general.
Though be mindful here,
which consulting firm
exactly you are joining.
And just as in one example in Germany,
there exists the large
consulting firm Roland Berger
and their structure is
that they are structured
in different competence centers.
And the usual way to
enter to start working
at Roland Berger is
that from the beginning,
you directly to commit to one
of these competence centers.
And then in most cases,
at least this is my understanding.
You will work the majority of your time
for the industry of the competence center
that you're part of.
Understand that there are
also some opportunities
to start as a generalist at Roland Berger,
but this is just one example.
Then there are others as well,
for instance, at Oliver Wyman,
as far as I'm informed, there
is a financial service's arm.
If you join there then
you will be dedicated
to the financial services practice.
So inform yourself, really make sure
that you understand
what the company really
is doing, obviously,
before you start there.
- This is something I
really appreciate about
my job because I always get
to be learning new things.
Now the flip side or the con to this
is that you can tend
to become a generalist
in lots of different industries
and not have a particular
expertise in any single one.
Over time, it is possible and normal
to gain an expertise in a
particular industry or issue,
but that obviously takes some time.
So at least in the beginning...
- So here, I would say at least based
on my experience at McKinsey,
I'd say it's kind of right
and wrong at the same time.
It's right in the sense that,
of course in the beginning,
you will not be a super deep expert
in one specific topic
and it takes some time
as she's also saying.
And yes, if you really
switch industry to industry,
then will be quite hard for you
and will take some time
until you really gain
this deep industry expertise.
But the other side of things is that,
especially if you decide
to early on pursue projects
that are specifically
in one industry only,
or at least the majority of projects
in that specific industry,
I would argue that you
will build industry expertise much quicker
and much more deeply than you would
in an average corporate
role in the industry.
And the reason is that
you will do projects
in all different types of
companies of that industry,
seeing lots of different
functions in the industry,
working together with very
senior employees of the industry.
And I trust this is really
the accelerated type
of career development and experience.
And if you want to try to get
a similar experience like that
in industry, if you just start in one
of a normal industry
role in that industry,
this will be difficult and it
would take your much longer.
So from that sense,
I would argue that actually in consulting,
you can gain and collect
that industry experience
much more quickly than
if you would just start at
an average corporate role.
- I think part of your career and at least
for the first several years,
you're probably going to be working
in an array of industries
rather than focusing
in on a single one depending
on the firm you're at.
So maybe you're at a consulting firm
that has a very specific
focus, but in general,
as a consultant, you're working
from industry to industry.
So you tend to get a little bit
of a surface level knowledge
across all different
kinds of industries so...
- And here, I just want to add,
or just kind of sharpen
your perception that
it's really important what
your consulting background is.
So from what type of consulting
firm you're coming from.
And I think what's important
to understand is that Kchoi,
as far as I understand her profile,
she is coming from a rather boutique type
of consulting firm.
She's coming from a change
management consulting firm
and firms like that focus
on really one specific topic
in that case change management.
And now, this is accurate
how I see her profile
and this knowledge is to be
contrasted with firms like MBB
or even other like large
strategy consulting firms,
also tier two strategy consulting firms
that have a much broader perspective
of tasks that they work.
So the types of projects that you will
do will be much broader,
which will help you to gain a
much more deep understanding
of a certain industry.
- Second pro, which is related
is that you get to work on
lots of different projects.
So not only do you get
to work in different
and with different companies,
but you also get to do different projects
as in solve different issues for them.
In the video that I mentioned
at the beginning of this video,
I sort of break down what
those different issues are.
So you can check that
out, to learn a bit more.
For me, I work on multiple
different projects
for different clients at the same time.
There are other
consultancies where you are
on one project for a set number of months.
- And just to add in here,
now from the MBB perspective
here in the first years,
you will always like 99% of the times,
you will be dedicated to one project.
You will not work at
different projects separately.
This only starts once you
are a senior project lead,
once you want to make the transition
to become a junior partner,
this is the menu start,
maybe leading and have been responsible
for two or three projects in parallel.
But this is now a step in the career
that is many years down the line.
So in the first three,
four, or five years,
this is not what will happen.
You will be dedicated to one project
and at least not relative to the types
of projects that you will do at MBB,
but also time wise be
completely impossible
to different projects or many projects,
as parallel regarding your time budget,
this just would not be feasible.
- But either way,
you get to switch out your projects
and do something a little
new every single time.
The con is that naturally,
you're gonna like some
projects more than others.
So you're gonna have some
ups and downs in terms
of how much you're enjoying your work.
You might be staffed on a
project for three months
that you absolutely love.
And then the next one comes along
and it's a six-month project
that you're just not as passionate about
or excited about as you move.
- Yes, I can fully agree with that.
That is completely accurate.
For sure doesn't matter to
what consultant you talk to.
Everybody reconfirm that there
are some projects that they really liked.
And then there are some projects
that were really bad for
all kinds of reasons, right?
This is completely normal,
but here I'd say the
positive if now I compare
that to a corporate job.
That it's even more digital, right?
I mean, either you get
along with your team,
you get along with your boss,
you like your work or you end
up actually not liking it.
But what you do in a corporate
role, if you don't like it?
Then pretty much the only choice
that you have is either to
transition within the company,
if that is even possible,
or really need to quit your job
and look for something else.
But the positive thing in consulting
from my perspective at least is that yes,
maybe there was a bad project which went
on for a couple of months
that you really disliked.
But then this project will be over.
Then you can now completely
go out there on a new choice.
You can go on a new project,
you can work together with new people.
And then over time,
you get to know the people
that you really enjoy working with.
You better understand for yourself,
what the projects are
that you enjoy doing.
And then can actively start
to pursuing these types of projects
and these types of
colleagues, more and more.
- Move up in your career
and gain more experience
then you can start to not
only gain more expertise
in a specific area but also have more
of a say in the projects that you're on.
But when you're first starting out
and in those first several years,
you have to work a little bit harder
to get the projects that you want to get.
- Also completely agree on that.
So the staffing market, which
she's referring to, right?
So the options of projects that you have,
they very much depend on
your internal reputation.
So the more you are
considered as a rock star,
as a high performer,
the more people will
want to work with you.
So basically, the better choices you have
and now you want to choose your project.
And of course, at the beginning,
nobody really knows you.
You're kind of one of many new associates
and then you kind of need to earn
and develop your reputation over time.
And this will then take some time
until you have developed
that, but then once you do it,
it will significantly help you
to then really do only
specifically the projects
that you want to do.
- Third pro is travel.
Now, not all consultants travel
because you might have some that are based
in a particular office and all the clients
are local so there isn't
much traveling going on.
But a lot of consultants do have to travel
around the US or even internationally
to meet with their clients.
Sometimes they'll get staffed
on a project that is
in a really cool place,
but I would actually say that the pro
from this is not so
much the travel itself,
but the rewards and
the status that you get
from all that travel. Personally-
- That is completely accurate.
So I have a whole wallet
just of bonus cards,
of all kinds of hotel chains and airlines.
You know, you have like
all these gold platinum,
diamond status cards from
all these different chains.
And then this is something
that you can also leverage
for your private, for your
personal vacations, right?
Because then of course it
will be treated accordingly
in these institutions.
Then you use that for
private reasons as well.
So yes, these are perks
of being a consultant.
This is correct.
- Most of my projects are based in the US
and so I've done travel
to Nashville, Houston,
Philadelphia, kind of all over the US
and not so much internationally yet.
I'm definitely always
expressing my interests
at work and traveling
internationally for a project.
So hopefully something will
come up that is the right fit.
But usually, when I have a work trip
and I'm traveling for
client work, I'm just there,
like the night before a meeting,
then go to the meeting in the morning
and then I'm flying
back home that evening.
So there isn't usually that much time
to do any actual exploring or traveling.
But because of all the travel that I do,
I gain status with my
preferred airline and hotel.
So you just get to reap the benefits of...
- Yeah so here she just said
that pretty much you'll start
in the morning flying somewhere.
And then in the evening, she flies out.
So this is not really the
rhythm that you will have
on your average MBB project
at a normal MBB project
and of course, here
there also some changes.
But usually, you'll fly
in on Monday morning
and then fly out on Thursday evening.
This is kind your standard workweek.
And then within the workweek,
like Monday to Thursday,
you will stay at the work client-side,
and then usually stay at a hotel.
The only exception of cause
is if you do a project
in your hometown, and then,
of course, you can just work or stay
at home then in the evening.
And then on top of that,
you might fly out or even other locations,
maybe you have a workshop
within the week in another city,
in another country, maybe
even in another continent.
So this is then the travel that even comes
on top of that, but kind of the baseline
is staying Monday to
Thursday at your client.
- Like upgrades and things like that.
It also means that I can rack up miles
and be able to make trips
based solely on my miles.
So I am paying nothing or just paying like
a $5 fee to book a plane ticket.
The only con I would say
that comes with traveling
for work is that it is much harder
to gain a healthy work-life balance.
It can be hard to get into a routine.
For example, meal prepping
is pretty impossible
to do if your schedule
is constantly changing,
or even if you're a consultant who travels
from Monday to Thursday,
then you're only home for
a few days out of the week.
So you tend to do things like going out
to eat instead of prepping your
meals and things like that.
Also, when you-
- I just want to stress and underline this
because here again, I completely agree.
And the problem is that in
most cases, Monday morning,
you will need to wake up really early
to get one of the earlier flights.
So depending a bit on your location,
the connection often you will need
to wake up at 5:00 a.m.
sometimes even earlier.
So this means you'll
ready start your work week
with some kind of sleep deficit.
And then this just continuous
building over the workweek,
and then usually on Thursday evening,
or then when the week is over,
you really need to do lots
of sleeping on the weekend
to recover of course now,
but depending on your
individual sleep needs.
But this then leads to really don't having
that much time also not on the weekends.
And this is of course why this travel can
be quite a broad and then it adds
to the not so ideal work-life
balance for many projects.
- You travel a lot for work,
your work time and personal time tend
to blend together a lot.
For example, sometimes
I need to book a flight
that doesn't get me home
until 11:30 at night,
which means a lot of my personal time
has been taken up by work.
Pro no number four is that you get to work
with a lot of big companies,
often fortune 100 companies
that are really cool
and well known.
That means you might get to go
to the headquarters of a
really well-known company,
meet with leaders there.
And it's just really cool that you get
to help shape companies
that are so well known across the world.
- I agree with that.
This is indeed what
you will frequently do.
And of course, it also
depends a bit on your taste.
So for me personally,
one of the best experiences I had
was rather working
for some more medium-sized
companies in consulting.
Not necessarily the very big corporates
and the main reason being that there
are sometimes at least I
felt like the possibilities
that you have, the things
that you can really change the time
to impact the path to
impact was even short.
I was even more direct,
but now this might also
be a question of personal preference.
So yes, of course, you really work
with very large clients
and you will meet lots of
senior executives this way.
- Con is that those companies
and clients could be a lot more demanding.
This is really a generalization
because some people and
clients you'll just get
along with better on a personal level,
just because your working styles
or your personalities match.
So regardless of the company,
there are gonna be some clients
that are more demanding or
more difficult to work with,
and others that are a
little easier to work with.
But I would say that the bigger the client
or more well known the client
is there's just that much more pressure
to make sure you're performing
and bringing results, and-
- So, here I'd say I didn't see
that correlation that strongly, right?
I had great clients to work
with at very large companies
that are super difficult people to work
with at smaller companies.
But overall, I agree that
the type of clients you have,
or you can work together
with them really shapes your experience.
And it can be really hard as a consultant
if you just don't get along
way with your clients.
So this is for sure, very decisive factor.
- Pro number five is that the compensation
or the pay is usually pretty good.
According to Glassdoor, the average salary
for a consultant in the
US is about $79,000,
which when you compare to a
salary for a software engineer,
for example, is actually kind of low.
But when you look at the median salary
in the US as a whole, which is $61,000,
then it's actually on the
more highly compensated side.
The con is that while
you might earn more money
than you would in some other careers,
because of some of the
challenges I mentioned earlier
in the video, like
demanding work schedules
and difficulty to achieve work,
life balance, a lot of consultants tend
to get burned out and leave
after just a few years.
For example-
- So here just to react to that.
So on the salary side,
of course, she is right.
Yes, consulting, in general,
is good and rather high paying
career for many of them.
And then it's also no secret
that the MBB consulting firms are one
of the firms that pay the
highest salaries, right?
So you can expect yourself being
even at the higher end
of all the spectrum.
So yes, of course, the salaries are high,
but what she also rightfully explains
is that the demands are
high on you as well.
So you will have a less work-life balance.
There will be quite a
significant amount of stress
and pressure on you.
And yes, some people do
burn out and do struggle.
And it is also correct
that after some years,
many leave the consulting firm, though,
I would argue that this is not only due
to burnout in the work-life pressure,
but also just for other
career-related choices as well.
- Though at BCG, 43% of the employees
have been there for less than two years
and 77% have been there
for less than five years.
So despite the pay
because of the lifestyle
of consulting, a lot of consultants
tend to leave after just a few years.
Now as the last pro and flip side
to that many of these consultants leave
their jobs because they have
an even better opportunity,
whether it's job at a different company,
or maybe it's an acceptance
to a prestigious business school.
Whatever the reason having
that consulting experience
on your resume makes you
a very valuable asset,
which is why so many people decide
to go into consulting in the first place.
- So, yes, I agree with that.
Consulting is a great career choice
and also does open many doors for you.
And especially now with an MBB background,
these are of course kind
of household name consulting brands.
And there are different firms
that really specifically
look out for these profiles
to then hire.
So yes, if you have this background,
it is a great career choice.
It can open many doors for you.
Of course, there are other choices,
other paths that you can go
that might provide you with
great opportunities as well.
But of course and this
is from my experience,
what I've seen, this is
something that might be a path,
very worth going.
That's it, guys.
I hope you took some valuable
information out of there.
And if you have any questions,
just leave me a comment
below in the comment section
and I will do my very best
to answer every single one.
If you took any value
out of this video please
destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And if you want to see
more content like that,
subscribe to my channel.
I'm uploading at least one
new video every Saturday.
On my channel, I talk about my experiences
being a former McKinsey
strategy consultant.
And I want to help you
to become successful
in the first years of your career.
And if you want to see even more from me,
I also have an Instagram channel my handle
is @firmlearning.
And I also have an email
mailing list you can sign up
for that for even more content
the sign-up link is below
in the video description.
Thank you guys for watching
hope you're all having
a great day and see you next Saturday.